- There is concern the coming months
could create a twindemic.
- COVID is continuing
to surge unfortunately.
Doctors are now warning the flu
will also be a major threat
over the next few months.
- When flu does come back,
and it will come back,
it's gonna come back very aggressively.
- [Narrator] Health experts are warning
that this year's flu
season could be much worse
than last year's.
The CDC says from 9 million
to 45 million people
in the US get infected with
the flu annually leading
to 12,000 to 61,000 deaths.
But that wasn't the case last year.
Last year's flu season
was nearly nonexistent.
Public health and clinical
laboratories reported
only a few thousand cases
of the flu for the season.
The COVID pandemic is a big reason
why those numbers were so low.
WSJ reporter, Felicia Schwartz,
has been reporting on
the upcoming flu season.
- All of the experts and virologists
that I spoke to in the course
of reporting all of this out said
that there will definitely
be more flu than last year
and it could potentially be an earlier
and more severe season just as a result
of the weird dynamics last year.
(pensive music)
- [Narrator] The flu virus
can spread to other people
through exposure, mainly
from droplets made
when people who have the
flu cough, sneeze or talk.
Less often, a person might get the flu
from contact with surfaces
that have flu virus on it.
And since the start of the pandemic,
health experts have found COVID spreads
in much the same way.
During last year's flu season
with the roll out of COVID
vaccines just getting started,
much of the US was in lockdown.
Social distancing
guidelines were in effect
and many people were masked.
All things that help
prevent the spread of COVID
and also help prevent the flu.
Now COVID vaccines are widely available
and people are interacting more.
- People are back at school,
back at work to some extent.
Depending on where you live in the US,
there are or aren't social
distancing restrictions,
like mask wearing and congregating
in large groups and so on.
And so there is a lot more
opportunity for the flu
to spread this year.
- [Narrator] As a population,
there's also less immunity
to the flu this year.
Population immunity occurs
when people are naturally
infected by the virus
or have received a vaccine.
Since so few people were
infected with the flu last year
because of social distancing,
people haven't been able to build up
their natural immune defenses.
This lack of immunity could contribute
to what some health experts
are calling a twindemic.
It refers to the threat
of a severe flu outbreak
on top of the COVID-19 pandemic,
which could be detrimental
to the healthcare system.
(pensive music)
- And I think the fear
from health authorities
is that hospitals could
be further overwhelmed.
One hospital administrator was telling me
maybe they'd have to
cut back on clinic hours
or reschedule other procedures
if they've having to make
these kinds of choices.
They might have to scale some things back.
- [Narrator] This overlap
could also cause confusion
among people above
whether they have COVID-19
or the flu.
Because they have similar symptoms,
it could be hard to diagnose
which condition people have
based on the symptoms alone.
The main difference between the two
is that COVID symptoms typically appear
about five days after infection
but symptoms can appear 2
to 14 days after infection.
And flu symptoms usually appear
about one to four days after infection.
(pensive music)
The good news is the best ways
to prevent catching the flu
are the ones many people
are already familiar with.
- Infectious disease experts
and epidemiologists really urge you
to get a flu shot.
On top of that, hand
washing, good hygiene.
If you're already wearing masks
and practicing social
distancing for corona,
that definitely can't hurt you
if you're looking to
avoid catching the flu.
- [Narrator] The flu season
commonly strikes the US October
through May with cases peaking
in December through February.
So the CDC recommends
getting a flu shot every year
by the end of October to get ahead of it.
(pensive music)
The CDC says you can get both the flu shot
and the COVID vaccine,
including boosters at the same time,
which wasn't the guidance last year.
- The shots were so new,
they didn't really have enough information
to make their recommendation
but now they're saying yes,
you can go get those two shots
at the same time.
So depending also on the booster campaign,
maybe there'll be some more
co-administration of shots.
- [Narrator] As far as side effects
from taking both the COVID
vaccine and the flu shot
at the same time,
the CDC says the side
effects people experience
are similar to what they experience
when the vaccines are given separately.
Some pharmaceutical companies
are even working on a combined flu shot
and COVID vaccine that
could be administered
in the same jab.
But there's no clear timeline yet
on when those would be available.
While experts believe this flu season
could strike earlier and
more severely than usual,
there's still no guarantee it will be.
- One person I interviewed
described it to me
as a tricky devil.
It's very hard to predict.
So I think there's a general feeling
that it will be worse,
and some people think it could be very bad
but it's kind of hard
to know at this point.
If you're worried about the flu,
probably the single
best thing you could do
is go out and take a shot.
(pensive music)